- All right, hi everyone.
Thank you so much for joining us today
on this first morning of re:Invent 2025.
Just if you wish, a show
of hands for any of you
who this is not your
first session for today.
Nice, I got some early
starters, I like it.
All right, so my name is Christine Megit,
and I am a Microsoft Licensing
Specialist here at AWS,
and I'm joined today by my colleagues,
GianPaolo and Valerie.
And today, we're gonna speak to you
about enterprise software
licensing and optimization on AWS.
There is gonna be a focus
on Microsoft licensing
just because we do have some new features
that we wanna highlight today,
so we're excited to share that with you.
And before I begin, I'm just gonna start
with a bit of a quote.
Most presentations like to start
with an impactful or motivational quote.
I'm not sure that's what we have here,
but this is something that
we do here from customers
on a regular basis at least once a week.
So Microsoft licensing especially
can be really difficult,
and we're here today to kind of break down
some of that complexity for you.
Microsoft licensing is complex,
there's different agreement
types, different license models,
is the product eligible for
License Mobility benefits?
Show of hands if anyone knows
about License Mobility benefits.
Good, all right, nice.
So today, we're gonna speak
to you about the optimization
and licensing assessment,
Val's gonna kick that off.
That's a fully funded program that we have
for Enterprise workloads,
not just Microsoft licensing.
I'm gonna take over again
and I'm gonna talk to you about
bringing your own license,
as well as some of our
License Included offerings.
And then I'll go into some
licensing optimization
best practices, including
highlighting some new features
that we are going to announce
that will help you save some costs.
Then I'll hand it over to GianPaolo,
and he's going to speak to you
about Optimize CPU for License Included,
which is one of the new
features we wanna highlight,
and also provide a live demo
for AWS Compute Optimizer
and Optimize CPU.
Then we'll kick it back over
to Valerie who's gonna discuss
how to get started, how to
start realizing these savings
and these new features, especially
through our OLA program.
All right, I'm gonna hand
it over to you Valerie, so.
- Thanks Christy, awesome.
All right, so a question for the audience,
how many of you have ever
googled Microsoft licensing
and immediately regretted it?
Yes, all right, I see a lot
of hands, that was surprising.
Great audience engagement.
All right, so how do you
make informed decisions
about migrating to the cloud
without becoming an expert
in optimization strategies
or getting that PhD in Microsoft licensing
that Christine mentioned?
Well, the good news is that
we have a program built
at AWS for this.
So the Optimization and
Licensing Assessment program
or OLA program that Christine
mentioned is purposely built
to help you optimize both your compute
and your licensing costs
when you're considering
a migration to AWS.
My name's Valerie Rosenfield,
I'm a part of the OLA program.
I've been on this team
for about five years,
serving our customers as a
Migration Assessment Specialist.
So I help customers when they
are considering migrating
all workloads, but specifically for today,
Microsoft workloads to the cloud,
review what they have
in their environment,
understand what their key
business priorities are,
any open questions that they have,
and then recommend an assessment process
that will get them answers
in the most efficient manner.
There we go, there's the OLA slide.
Awesome, all right, so OLA
is all about simplifying
your migration and your licensing journey.
What are the benefits for customers?
Actually I'll ask another question.
How many of you are customers
who are already running on AWS today?
Oh, nice, awesome, you will
love this presentation then.
How many customers are
considering migrating
to the cloud in one to two years,
but don't run any workloads
yet on AWS, anybody?
Awesome, okay, any
partners in the audience?
Awesome, awesome.
Okay, that's great context for talking
about how OLA helps simplify
the migration journey.
It's good to know who we
have here in the audience.
First off, OLA is a data-driven
assessment that is built
to answer three key
questions when customers
are considering migration
or post migration,
which it sounds like is most relevant
to the audience here today.
The first is collecting an inventory.
So we need to know what
is in your environment
and how is it being used.
That visibility is crucial
because cloud optimization
is all about running
as lean as possible, as
many of you will know,
and we can't optimize what we can't see,
so the OLA starts with
that baseline inventory
of understanding what you
have in the environment.
Next, we assess the
business case for the cloud
or we assess how you can
optimize your existing footprint
that is already running in AWS.
So we will review your
environment to understand
if rehosting, replatforming,
or refactoring
is the right approach,
show you costing options
for each of those, and along the way,
we'll show you how you can optimize
both your compute and your licensing.
All right, so for customers
who are considering
a new migration to the cloud,
the OLA data also serves
as the building blocks
for helping you plan the journey.
So a lot of times we are...
You're working with a
partner on the assessment,
sometimes you're working
with the AWS account team,
and this data just helps them
dive deeper to understand
what your priorities are,
what your timelines are around migration,
and importantly, this program
also helps qualify you
for different AWS programs and incentives.
All right, what is the
impact of OLA in numbers?
So first off, as Christine mentioned,
the OLA comes at no cost to customers.
This is an investment that AWS
makes in setting customers up
for success as they
migrate and post migration
for those of you who are
already running in AWS.
Next, we see that customers that perform
one of these exercises and
take the recommendations
that are surfaced in the OLA
achieve a 36% cost reduction.
Finally, migrations are about 34% faster
when you're executing the
migration based on real data
instead of guesswork.
All right, so we will zoom in a little bit
on the Microsoft side of the assessment.
So what will you get from the
Microsoft licensing analysis
that is a part of an OLA, you know,
that's why most of you are here today.
When customers are considering a migration
of their Microsoft workloads to AWS,
they come to us with five
key questions normally,
and OLA has the answers for those.
The first is, what does my Windows
and SQL Server footprint look like?
So that goes back to collecting
that baseline inventory as the first step.
And we'll talk about
process-wise a little bit,
what that looks like
on the following slide.
Next is, how can I reduce my SQL cores?
So we see that the
majority of our customers
spend on Microsoft products
is typically on SQL Server,
especially in terms of what
gets migrated to the cloud.
So that is top of mind product
when customers are thinking
about cost optimization.
Next, can I bring my own
licenses to AWS or BYOL?
Most of you will be familiar
with that terminology.
The good news is the
answer is typically yes,
there are, of course,
nuances and that's exactly
what the OLA will help you navigate.
Even if you can bring
your Microsoft licenses
to AWS, should you?
And today, we're gonna be
talking about an exciting feature
that is released for
License Included workloads
that can help reduce
that spend versus BYOL.
So in the future, we actually do think
that License Included options will become
more cost competitive for customers,
so stay tuned for that.
And finally, how do I optimize
my Enterprise Agreement,
my EA renewal with Microsoft as I migrate?
So if you can execute one
of these assessments shortly
before your EA renewal,
that's really the prime time
to do it because then you can
actually realize the savings
that will surface to you in the OLA.
As many of you will know, this
is usually a three-year term,
so if you can do this exercise
in preparation for that,
you'll avoid that lock-in
or be able to choose more flexible options
when you do renew with Microsoft.
All right, so tying it back
to that first question,
how do we collect an
inventory of your Windows
and SQL Server footprint?
OLA can support you in two ways for this.
If you have a tool on
premise that already has
an inventory of your
environment, has limited gaps,
it has your SQL inventory,
you can supply that to us
instead of installing a tool,
which sometimes takes some time,
and we'll clean it, consolidate it,
and analyze it for you, turn
it into an AWS business case.
If you don't have a tool on
premise with high coverage
or you just wanna get a fresh dataset,
AWS, this is part of the
investment that we make
in the OLA program, we'll
fund a discovery tool for you
to collect the information.
So there are a few tools
that we use for this process.
You may be familiar with
some of these names.
This isn't the full tool set,
but it's what we use on the
majority of engagements.
We have our first-party AWS
Migration Evaluator tool
and two third-parties named
Cloudamize and modelizeIT.
In terms of the information that we get
from Microsoft workloads, you're
going to get the additions
and the versions of your Windows
and SQL Server deployments.
We'll get information on
how those are utilized.
So the CPU memory storage utilization,
and then the instances and
databases that are running.
And the purpose of this is
just to inform the Windows
and SQL Server optimization
analysis that we'll walk you
through on the following slide.
All right, let's get to the good stuff.
This is a sample OLA output
from a recent customer engagement,
and this was an existing customer in AWS,
I think it will resonate with the audience
that we have here today.
This customer was a
large healthcare customer
with $16.5 million of EC2 spend.
So the first optimization
that we are going to surface
in an OLA is right-sizing your workloads.
So this is the basic level
one version of optimization
where you are just running the
most cost effective instance
that meets your performance needs.
AWS has a variety of
different instance families,
and so a lot of times, you're running one
that doesn't perfectly
suit whether that workload
is compute memory or storage intensive,
and just switching the
family can reduce your costs.
In this case, right-sizing
just their Linux EC2 workloads
save them about 12%.
This is savings opportunity,
so perhaps they execute on 50% of those,
but still pretty meaningful
savings at $1 million.
The next optimizations are
specific to Windows EC2
and SQL EC2 workloads,
and this is what we're gonna dive deeper
into with Christine and GP
later in the presentation,
so I won't harp on it too much.
But an exciting new feature
that allows you to tailor
the number of vCPUs that you have
on your Windows and SQL
License Included instances,
as many of you will know,
those licensing models are core based,
so anytime you're
reducing the core counts,
you're gonna reduce your licensing costs,
and this actually comes
directly off of your AWS bill.
So if you're purchasing Windows
or SQL licensing from AWS,
which most of you will be,
this will reflect a
reduction on your AWS spend.
In this case, it was a
13% additional savings,
so another $2 million that...
Before this launch wasn't even possible.
This is an incremental strategy
that is really gonna make
some important savings
changes for our customers.
And finally, the template.
The standard output that
you're gonna get for SQL,
the additional optimization strategy
is identifying SQL workloads
that look like they're non-prod.
Microsoft has a free edition of SQL Server
called Developer edition,
and so during the OLA,
we'll flag instances that
look like they are non-prod
based on their naming convention.
So dev, test, QA, et cetera.
We'll summarize the cores
that are running on those,
show you what you're likely spending
on your Microsoft contracts
for those non-prod cores,
so you can make an informed decision
about whether you should
downgrade to that Free edition
of Microsoft SQL Server
called Developer edition.
In this case, it was an
incremental 2% savings,
so a little bit lighter
than the other savings,
but sometimes this is the easiest one
for customers to execute, so
it's still pretty helpful.
Awesome, so cumulatively this was
a $5 million savings
opportunity for the customer
and they were very
pleased because for them,
even if they only achieved
25% of these savings,
it would still be over $1
million, which meant...
Was a meaningful cost reduction
and a reinvestment opportunity for them.
All right, wrapping up this section.
So the final question
that we usually address
in an OLA is how do I optimize
my Microsoft Enterprise Agreement renewal?
Again, we highly encourage
doing one of these exercises
six months to one year in
advance of your EA renewal,
so you can go into that conversation
with the insights from the OLA,
especially if you're seriously
considering a cloud migration
within the next year as well.
Is anybody coming up on
their Microsoft EA renewal
in the next year?
Anyone know?
We don't know.
Not procurement people it sounds like.
All right, well, there
are some standard insights
that will surface as
a part of this process
and then we have experts
who can dive deeper,
look at your unique contracts
if you are interested
in that type of tailored analysis.
But the first one is, for Windows Server,
most customers are gonna
migrate to shared tenancy in AWS
and that comes with the
Windows License Included.
So our standard recommendation
is to avoid double payment,
you should discontinue
the payments that you make
to Microsoft annually for
Windows Software Assurance
to reduce your net costs.
For SQL Server, we encourage
customers to switch
from perpetual licensing to subscription
in certain scenarios, this is
not right for every customer.
But if you know that
you will be optimizing
your cores further after migration,
but you don't have time to
do it before your EA renewal,
a good option can be to switch
to subscription licensing
so you have the flexibility
to true-down sooner.
EA is a three-year lock in
unless you do that subscription licensing,
which would give you more flexibility
to true-down after a year.
So it's something to consider
if you know you're gonna optimize,
but you can't do it immediately.
Next, and again, this is gonna tie to GP's
and Christine's presentation
on Optimize CPU for
License Included workloads,
but evaluating whether License
Included is a better option
for you than Bring-Your-Own-License.
Outside of it becoming
more cost competitive
with this new feature, a lot of customers
just prefer not to manage
licensing with Microsoft.
Makes sense, rightfully so.
So you can outsource that to AWS
and we manage the licensing
payments to Microsoft
when you go License Included.
And finally, this is not specific,
we talked a little bit about
addition downgrades before.
This is more associated with
your production workloads.
So if you have production workloads
that are running Enterprise
edition software,
a lot of times, you're not
using the Enterprise features
and it's actually less expensive
to buy new perpetual standard licenses
than just to renew the
annual maintenance payments
on Enterprise Edition.
Enterprise is about four times more
as expensive as Standard.
So that's another thing
that you can consider.
Assess whether you're
actually using the features
and if not, it might be a good opportunity
just to make the change, bite the bullet,
and downgrade to a Standard edition.
Awesome, so these are the
standard recommendations
that you will get in an OLA output.
But behind every OLA, we have
a team of licensing experts
like myself, like GP, like Christine,
who you can tap into
if you have more custom
or specific asks, and they can also answer
follow-up questions on
the licensing insights
that we present.
Christine is the expert
in Microsoft licensing,
she's our go-to, so
I'll pass it over to her
to give more detailed
insights on how to optimize
and manage in the cloud.
- Thank you so much, Valerie.
All right, so now, I'm gonna go over a bit
of licensing information for you.
I'll start with Bring-Your-Own-License
and how that works on AWS.
So I mentioned earlier,
it looks like a lot of you
maybe are already familiar
with License Mobility benefits,
but if you're not familiar,
this is a Software Assurance benefit
that allows you to bring
your eligible products
to a shared tenancy
environment such as EC2 on AWS.
To qualify, the product
itself must be eligible
for License Mobility benefits.
So it's not necessarily enough
that there's Software Assurance,
the product also must be eligible,
and again, the Software Assurance
and eligible subscriptions are required,
and this can be deployed on
shared or dedicated tenancy,
it doesn't have to be shared.
And there is a License Mobility
verification form as well
that you are to fill out up
to 10 days after deployment.
For some products that are eligible
for License Mobility benefits,
we have Azure DevOps, Exchange
Server, Project Server,
SharePoint Server, SQL Server, of course,
System Center Server,
and there's some others
in there as well.
So just to dive in a bit
more into SQL Server BYOL,
'cause it is a very popular
product for customers to bring.
If we're looking at the core model,
one core license is gonna cover one vCPU
on shared tenant EC2.
There is a four core licensing
minimum set by Microsoft.
So you could potentially
deploy on an instance
smaller than four vCPUs,
but you would still need to assign
four cores of licensing as a minimum.
Again, Software Assurance is required,
and if we look here at this chart of...
The r7a instance family,
you'll see the r7a.large
does have two vCPUs,
but again, you would assign four cores
just because of that four
core licensing minimum.
If you were to deploy on
the r7a.24xlarge instance,
you'd bring 96 cores of SQL.
Now, for the server CAL model,
we don't come across this as often,
but it is definitely something
that some customers do still have,
for specific use cases.
Here you're just gonna
have one server license
per EC2 instance or per VM,
plus you'll have the
additional user or Device CALs
for all users or devices that have access,
and that's direct or indirect access.
You'll also need the Software Assurance
or eligible subscriptions
on the server licenses
and also the the CALs.
Again, just a reminder
that License Mobility
verification form is required.
A bit more on BYOL for SQL Server,
there is a passive failover
benefit available for customers
that are bringing their licenses
with their Software Assurance.
Again, this is a Software
Assurance benefit
and it is one-to-one, so
it does work differently
than maybe what you can do on-premises.
So that is a key note to consider.
So one SQL Server EC2
instance, for example,
allows you to deploy a secondary
passive SQL Server instance
of the same size or
smaller in terms of vCPUs.
This is not eligible for
active-active configurations.
If we look at this example
here, two R5 instances,
eight vCPUs each, the
passive instance doesn't need
to be licensed for SQL,
but the active instance
would be licensed for SQL.
So overall, eight cores of
SQL Server licensing required
for this configuration.
Now, for non-production,
Val touched on this already,
but SQL Server Developer
edition is free for you to bring
for non-production workloads,
so it is a BYOL scenario.
And with the release of SQL
Server 2025 just the other day,
not sure if you saw that, but there is now
two Developer editions
available for that version.
One for Enterprise edition,
one for Standard edition,
which is great for those of you
that are only looking to deploy.
In Standard edition, once
you move to production,
you can use that Standard
edition, Developer edition.
For anyone deploying SQL Server
2022 or earlier versions,
you'd still use the Standard...
Developer edition that covers all features
up to Enterprise edition.
And as a reminder to use
this Developer edition,
you cannot be connected
to a production database
or it can't be used for DR as well.
And it does include all the same features
as Enterprise edition except, of course,
where you're using the new 2025 version
that does have a Standard edition.
And as with any BYOL on AWS,
you are required to bring
your own media or install
for the products that you're bringing.
Now, I'm gonna shift
gears to bringing products
that do not have License
Mobility benefits.
There was some changes that were made
effective October 1st 2019.
These were changes
specifically impacted products
that are not eligible for
License Mobility benefits.
So this does not impact
anything I've just
spoken about previously.
To bring a product that is not eligible
for License Mobility benefits,
such as Windows Server,
the version you're deploying
first must be a version
that was released before October 1st 2019.
For Windows Server, that's
version 2019 or earlier only.
You must also have perpetual
licenses, not subscription.
And the licenses must have
been originally purchased
before October 1st 2019
or originally purchased within an EA term
that started before October 1st 2019.
So again, this impacted
products only not eligible
for License Mobility benefits,
that would be Windows Server,
Visual Studio, and Office applications.
SQL Server without Software
Assurance would also not have
License Mobility benefits, so
that would also be impacted
if you did not have Software
Assurance on your SQL.
Just to dive a bit more
into Windows Server BYOL,
as it does come up quite often.
If you have those eligible licenses
and you're deploying
version 2019 or earlier,
you would use dedicated
hosts and you would license
the total number of
physical cores of the hosts.
So if you're looking at
an R5 EC2 dedicated host,
for example, that has 48 physical cores,
you'd license 48 cores
Windows Server Datacenter,
and you'd be covered for
any number of R5 instances
that you can fit on that host.
This also is true for our
recently launched service,
Amazon EVS or Elastic VMware Service.
It is running on dedicated,
so it does allow you
to bring your Windows
Server licenses as well.
Again, Software Assurance is not required
for bringing Windows Server
because it doesn't have
License Mobility benefits.
So whether you're using BYOL
or you're moving to a
License Included model,
as Valerie mentioned, that's a great way
to reduce costs at your next renewal,
is to lower that Software Assurance
as you won't be needing it.
Now, for License Included
and some of the offerings we have there.
For Windows Server License Included,
this is most commonly used by customers
because it does allow customers
to deploy on shared EC2.
It covers any addition.
We don't always list an addition,
but our licensing agreement
with Microsoft is very specific,
very customized, and
it covers any addition.
It also includes unlimited
Windows Server CALs,
as well as two remote
desktop services connections
for each EC2 instance that
using License Included.
And again, this is a
required licensing option
on shared EC2.
It's also required for
versions 2022 and 2025
of Windows Server, and
that's because those versions
were released after the
October 1st 2019 changes.
These Windows Server License Included
is billed per vCPU per second
for on-demand instances.
It is an option that can
be used for external use.
So for example, if you are
an ISV or a SaaS provider
that was impacted by the SPLA BYOL changes
where Microsoft no longer
allows SPLA BYOL on AWS,
License Included is a compatible
option for those workloads.
And if you need additional
remote desktop services connections,
we do offer those as License Included.
But you can also BYOL or
bring your own RDS User CALs
with Software Assurance through
License Mobility benefits.
Now, for License Included SQL Server.
We offer this in the core model only,
so there's no CALs required.
We offer this in Standard,
Enterprise, and Web edition.
Again, with the release of SQL 2025,
there is no new Web edition available.
So 2022 Web edition is
the last edition available
and it is a very specific use case.
So Web edition can only be used
for publicly accessible websites.
If you're not familiar with that edition,
that probably means you can't use it,
but it is something that
we do offer for up to 2022.
All right, so this is also
billed per vCPU per second
for on-demand instances,
and it can also be used for external use.
So again, if you're an
ISV or a SaaS provider,
this option also replaces the
SPLA BYOL that was removed.
All right, so now,
onto some licensing
optimization recommendations
and best practices.
So we do have a free tool
called AWS License Manager.
This is a great tool to use
to input your licenses
that you're bringing.
It can also be used to take a look
at your License Included instances.
This is a great way to keep
track of what you're using.
You can use it also to integrate
with dedicated hosts and other services.
So I highly recommend checking this out,
if you haven't already.
It can be used with a variety
of different software.
It doesn't have to be Microsoft,
there's a lot of different
vendors that it supports,
and you can use it even for on-premises,
or workloads, and other clouds as well.
This is just a view of what it looks like
when you're inputting some licenses.
and you can choose whether you want
to enforce a license limit
or don't have it in
force where you just get
a warning message if you
go over your licensing.
If you are interested in
learning more about this tool,
I'm also speaking at a
second session on Thursday
called MAM321: Licensing
management and optimization
where we are gonna speak about
some new licensing features
through License Manager.
That's on Thursday, December
4th at the MGM Grand.
This QR code will take
you to the catalogs,
you can see where that's located.
All right, instance right-sizing.
As Valerie mentioned,
this is a core component
of our OLA offerings.
This can benefit License Included.
Our products are licensed per vCPU
for Windows Server and SQL Server,
so the more you're right-sized
on the instance size,
the more your licensing costs
will be right-sized as well.
For BYOL, this is also beneficial
because SQL licensing for
BYOL is licensed per vCPU
if you're bringing core licenses,
and again, right-sizing is
gonna optimize your licensing
that you're bringing over as well.
On the Windows Server side,
this can help in both ways.
BYOL, if you're right-sizing,
you can end up with fewer hosts,
which means lower infrastructure costs
and lower licensing costs as well.
And again, OLA, so that's
gonna help you figure
all of this stuff out.
Now, for a new feature that
we just recently launched,
Amazon EC2 High
Availability for SQL Server.
This is a new feature available
for License Included SQL
Server that now allows you
to not license the
passive or secondary node.
Previously, this was required,
you'd have to license both
if you were using License Included.
Now, if you're using License Included,
you will be exempt from the
SQL License Included costs
on that secondary passive node.
So this supports two EC2 instances
per SQL Server High Availability cluster.
It supports always on availability groups,
as well as failover cluster instances.
You only pay for the Windows
Server License Included costs
on the passive nodes,
as well as the compute costs, of course.
The passive SQL Server instance
needs to be the same size
or smaller than the active
SQL Server instance.
And this is available for
new and existing instances.
So you can go into the console
to update your instances
if you have these already
or you can use this for new deployments.
It does require AWS Systems
Manager Agent to be installed
and running on the
instances for this to work.
If you wanna learn more,
we do have this QR code here as well.
We have lots of documentation for you
including a blog that's
been released as well,
so check that out.
And for another new feature
that has been recently launched,
and this is gonna be spoken
about a lot in our session,
GP's gonna take over for me shortly,
but this is Optimize CPU
for License Included.
So previously to this
launch, customers could use
Optimize CPU to lower their
number of vCPUs on an instance,
which would let them bring
fewer SQL Core licenses.
This now is available for
License Included as well.
And it not only impacts SQL
Server License Included,
but it also impacts Windows
Server License Included.
So this is gonna be a
great way for customers
who for the most part have to use
Windows Server License
Included on shared EC2
if there's room for optimization there,
and to either disable hyper-threading
or use a specific number of vCPUs,
this will immediately lower
your License Included costs
for Windows Server, as well as SQL Server.
Using this feature, you
will see a separate billing
for licensing, so it will be broken out
of your EC2 instance costs, which is new.
Typically, without using this feature,
your License Included costs will be
within your compute costs.
This feature will separate those.
And again, this is available
for new and existing instances.
So great news here, here's just an example
of the x1e family type.
You can see the max vCPUs
is the default vCPUs,
the instance size comes with.
You can turn these down all the way
to the examples shown here.
But just a reminder, SQL Server licensing
is a four core minimum
even for License Included,
so we wouldn't necessarily recommend going
all the way down anyways, but
if you were to go below four,
you'd still see license
costs for four cores.
All right, so that's it for me,
I'm gonna hand it over to GP.
- Thank you.
So my name is GianPaolo Albanese,
I'm a Solutions Architect Specialist.
Been at AWS for eight years.
The one thing that I got
from the session so far
is that I have really
trouble sleeping at night.
So if you wanna fall asleep very quickly,
you can read about the licensing
that Microsoft provides.
I will appreciate actually
Polly, Amazon Polly,
to actually read it to me
very slowly and softly,
and you fall asleep right
away, or you can go to a bar.
But this is probably works best.
So let's move in and
talk about a little bit
about Optimize CPU and SQL Server.
So why is this important?
So SQL Server licensing
is based on active CPUs
that are visible to the operating systems.
And so what we are seeing more and more
is that customers need to
deploy larger EC2 instance sizes
because they have specific requirement,
either IOPS requirements
or memory requirements.
And so therefore, if you
want a 512 gigs of RAM
allocated to your instance,
you have to deploy
maybe an r6idn.16xlarge.
It's a lot of money, right?
And again, there is gold, right?
There's gold coins in there.
So every time you basically
spin one of these machines up
just to accommodate one of your workloads,
again, it's a huge cost
that happens on licensing.
And so again, what we're
trying to do is we're trying
to kind of minimize the cost.
So what can we do?
As already Valerie and
Christine mentioned,
we do have a new feature,
it's Optimize CPU.
And what Optimize CPU would
allow us to do is it allows you
to actually modify the
instance type after launch.
So what you can do is
after you start analyzing
your workload and trying
to figure out exactly
what really works or what
is the perfect balance
between CPU memory and storage,
then at that point you can
actually stop the instance
and start making some
modification to the instance.
In fact, some of the
things that you can do
or how this feature works
is that after you accept
the default instance
that you have deployed,
you can go back and you can
start working on disabling
the hyper-threading on the CPU.
So you allow now to modify that
after you stop the instance.
And what we notice that most of the times,
when you're dealing with high
performance compute workloads
or maybe someday it's dealing
with the scientific calculations,
disabling hyper-threading
actually helps a lot, right?
You see an improvement because
there is no context switching
with the operating systems.
And so at this point, what you can do
is you can also now go even further.
After you disable the hyper-threading,
you start analyzing your workload,
now, you can go back and say,
"Maybe I can actually
also trim down the CPUs.
I don't have to dedicate four
CPUs for my Windows Server,
maybe I can go for two," if
you're not running SQL Server.
Remember, SQL Server requires four CPUs,
there is no way around that.
So that's another way that
you can kind of reduce cost.
So what are some of the key benefits
that some of our customers seeing?
First of all, you start seeing a reduction
on your SQL Server cost,
especially with you
Bring-Your-Own-License into AWS,
and there is a new feature coming up
where this will available also
for License Included on SQL Server.
But what I also know, there's
a lot of commercial software,
they have specific
requirements that are many CPUs
you need to run to be compliant.
Especially if you have
like a third-party support
and you need to open up a case,
you wanna make sure that
you follow the guidelines
from the third-party vendor
or the the CALs application requirements.
Something else that you
can see is we seen...
Some customers seeing some
really performance improvements
when they disable the hyper-threading
on some of the workloads.
Again, you need to test that out,
and we do have CloudWatch and CloudMetrix
that you can kind of collect
or if you have your own collection agents,
you can kind of start
collecting this information
and analyze it often.
And again, we have another
exciting tool that we can use
to actually help you go
through and figure out exactly
what is working for your
particular workload.
And so we this, see some
customers now improving
and having performance improvement
just by disabling hyper-threading.
And also what they (indistinct) is another
is a lower infrastructure
cost, and that's key,
because, again, AWS is
a little differentiator
with other cloud providers you might see.
We always try to help
customers save costs, right?
We provide you the tools
to analyze your workload
and then you can work with any one of us,
a solutions architect or specialist,
to kind of help you kind of figure out
where can we kind of trim things
or kind of lower the trial a little bit
so that you can save some money.
So what are some of the best practices,
specifically when you're dealing
with SQL CPU optimization?
Well, there's some things
that you really need
to be careful and be watching out for.
So first things that we noticed
is that once you disable
the hyper-threading
on SQL Server specifically,
we don't see any major impact
on performance on the machine.
In fact, that's a quick win,
right, for saving money.
And the beauty of this is that we...
Especially if you're dealing
with online transactional processing,
actually benefits the operating system
and the server actually runs
much better and by performing.
The next steps, so with the first steps
you see almost 35% on cost.
But if you go to the next
steps and now start looking
and monitoring your environment even more,
you start realizing maybe
you can kind of throttle down
even the core count.
And if you do this, you
can actually achieve
a 47% cost savings without
impacting your workload.
Now, I wanna be extremely careful there.
You have to continuously
test the environment
and collect metrics to make sure
that you're actually
achieving those goals.
Because sometimes what's
happening is you might have
certain processes or certain systems
that at the end of the month
are very transactional,
they're running some
big batch jobs, right?
And you wanna minimize any
impact on your performance.
And the other thing I wanna mention is,
actually you need to monitor, you know,
the IOPS and CPU ratio.
So we found like a sweet spot,
7,000 to 8,000 IOPS per CPU
is the sweet spot where you can get
actually good performance,
and also there is a
cost savings associated.
If you start deviating from
this IOPS requirement per CPU,
if you go to high, you
have system contention.
'Cause what happens is
now the IOPS are very high
and what's happening in the subsystem
is actually working very, very hard.
So now, the storage IOPS system
is actually being impacted.
If you go the other way around
where you travel down the IOPS,
now, you're seeing that
you CPU is actually idling
and it's not doing anything,
it's waiting for the
system to provide data.
So again, testing is key
and you want to kind of
don't want to go...
You wanna kind of stay or monitor the IOPS
for your environment.
And lastly, test, test, test.
You have to test your workload,
test with load, with no load,
test over the weekend nights,
you know, Black Friday, just test it.
We have a lot of tools
that we can provide you.
We have CloudWatch metrics
that can basically help you
monitor all these things.
You can also set alerts as well
or you can create an SNS
topic and send the information
to your email or to a dashboard.
So now, it's part of the demo.
So how do you do this?
So let me just switch over to my screen,
and if everything works
well, there you go.
So you have your Console here, right?
Don't look at my bill.
This thing is bothering me.
There we go.
So a bunch of instances
running on my system, right?
And right now, I'm just gonna second guess
and see what's happening, right?
I have no metrics, but let's
say that I have this SQL Server
that I'm running on m5.xlarge, right?
And right now, if you look
at the instance, right,
if you don't know anything about m5.large,
you can actually see how many CPUs
are allocated to the system.
(GP hums)
Oh, sorry, that's the guy.
There we go.
All right, once you look at the details,
you go on the bottom,
and you can actually see
some information about the server itself.
So right now, if you
can tell on the screen,
eight CPUs are actually allocated
to this virtual machine, it's by default.
So I deployed the SQL Server,
I've deployed Enterprise on it,
I automatically enabled eight CPUs on it.
But let's say that you wanna
actually now start streaming down
or start playing around
with the hyper-threading.
Well, your first thing you
have to do is you actually have
to stop the instance, right?
Now, once the instance is stopped,
it will take a couple
minutes, a minute or so.
We can actually go in there
and not stop playing around
with the hyper-threading first, right?
And you'll see that after you do that,
you can actually start
the instance up again
and it will actually now allocate only
the number of CPUs that I've...
Or vCPUS that I have allocated
to a particular system.
So let's refresh this real quick.
Okay.
All right, that's the guy.
So you go to Actions, you
go to Instance Settings,
and now, you have a new option
here that says Change CPUs.
Here it actually allows you
and it gives you a little snippet there.
It tells you that you
can lower your Windows
with SQL Server Standard
vCPU licenses, right?
By just playing around with these numbers.
The one thing that I'm gonna do
is I'm just gonna disable hyper-threading.
Right now, we have two
threads allocated per CPU
across my server.
Notice what happens.
First of all, you get this message
that if you are used to
looking at the billing
and the way the EC2 is actually charged,
usually if you do a License Included,
you only see one cost, right?
Once you actually start playing
it out with the threading
or a CPU course that you
enable and disabling,
it actually is gonna split the cost.
So you're gonna see two prices there.
One for the instance
and one for actually the number
of CPUs actually allocated.
So I'm just gonna change it.
The only thing you have to do after this
is just start the instance.
You give it a minute, right?
And now, you can see that the
number of vCPUs now it's four.
So going forward, if you
have a License Included
with SQL Server running on it,
you're gonna only pay for
the four licenses now,
instead of eight.
You can do this on every
single server across your fleet
and you're already gonna start
seeing some cost savings.
But obviously, you're gonna ask yourself,
"Am I gonna go through 5,000 servers
and start clicking on things,
and trying to figure out what
works, what doesn't work?"
Obviously you don't wanna
do that, right? (coughs)
So another tool that we have,
and I'm gonna switch
back to PowerPoint, yeah.
Is the AWS Compute Optimizer.
This is a great tool, and the reason why
is because it takes the
thought process figuring out
what work and what doesn't
work in your environment
to the next level.
So what is it?
It's actually powered by Machine Learning.
You're gonna hear about
AI across the board.
Well, this is actually a tool
that I really love to use
because it actually saves me a lot of time
when I start analyzing my environment,
and you will see why, right?
So it is powered by Machine Learning.
It actually analyzes historical data
that is being collected from your systems,
from CPU, memory, IOPS
consumption, and it starts
just tracking all these
data, right, internally.
It starts identify some patterns
and maybe you have missed.
So you run this in your
environment, you turn it,
literally, it's a flag that you enable,
and it starts analyzing your
environment for you, right?
And then what it starts doing,
it starts making predictions.
It starts telling you,
"Okay, you know what?
I see a cost savings of X
thousands of dollars a month
if you make these modifications."
In the past we had similar
tools, I kind of did this.
However, you only provide
you like, you know,
you could use Cost Explorer, right?
You can use AWS Budget, you
can use all these other tools.
I kind of combine 'em
together to give you that data
and then you have to figure out
what you wanna do with this data.
So what happens?
Well, as it goes through,
it starts looking at your EC2 instances,
it starts looking at
your auto scaling groups,
the EBS volume, the storage,
the Lambda function.
Now, we have also Aurora and RDS databases
that actually are being monitored as well,
and also we have ECS on
Fargate, and we are gonna have
more and more services being
monitored by Compute Optimizer.
Now, what happens, because it's using AI
to actually do all this, right?
It's all automated.
Think about this.
You have a guy working 24/7,
monitoring your environment,
collecting data constantly,
then using the data,
running some algorithm against it,
and then trying to figure out
what will work best for you.
So again, it's a predictive
cost optimizations.
So you really don't have to do anything,
you just have to turn on a flag.
It actually looks like your performance
on the subsystem as well.
So if you remember before,
we had to find a sweet spot,
7,000 AI, 8,000 IOPS per CPU,
we don't have to do that now, right?
The system will do that for you,
and it also it's gonna make
some data driven recommendations,
which is very cool.
So I just have a quick dashboard
and then we're gonna...
I'm gonna jump into my laptop again,
I'll show you my environment
'cause I had to collect some data first.
But for example, it gives you
eh, $185 a month cost savings.
Ah, not big deal, right?
You click on the EC2 instance,
but you can see there
on the left side all these other services
that it's actually
monitoring for you, right?
And again, like I mentioned before,
more and more service are gonna be added.
And then what it'll do is it actually make
a recommendation for you.
Look at all your environment,
it is actually looking at your workload,
and then it's gonna actually say,
"Wait a minute, some of these systems
are actually optimized, some
of them are over-provisioned."
And then it actually tells you
what is over provision, why.
In this case, CPU over provision,
EBS, IOPS over provision,
and so on and so forth,
because I haven't done
anything with these machines.
Basically the sitting IOP,
right, running something.
But if you look on the right pane,
it actually gives you a
estimated monthly cost
of what the cost savings are.
So if we go back to my screen, yep.
And we do AWS Cost Optimizer,
Compute Optimizer, right?
So let's look how my account looks like.
Definitely over provisioned.
There we go.
So I have cost saving.
This is just my personal account, right?
I can actually save $1,000 a month.
I mean AWS saves $1,000 'cause
I'm not paying for this.
But look at this, some of the
numbers, 15% cost savings.
And what I really like about this,
I can click on my EC2 instances,
and now, I have the
data that I need, right?
It tells me that my SQL Server
Optimize CPU is optimized,
but there is a bunch of other instances
that are not optimized.
Now, the cool thing about this
is that it's actually gonna start making
some recommendations of what
the current instance type is
and what is the recommended
instance size to go to.
Now, the other thing that you can also do
is start using this data to instead of
maybe changing instance sizes,
because now, we have the Optimize
CPU that we can leverage.
Go back and stop playing
around with the hyper-threading
and, you know, and turning
off the CPUs on your system.
So you don't necessarily, but
you can use this as a guide
to kind of help you through it.
Very cool stuff.
So the question that you might have now
is how to get started
with all of this, right?
So I'm gonna give it back
to Valerie to continue.
Thank you, Valerie.
- Awesome, thank you GP.
All right, so we've just seen
the power of Optimize CPU
for License Included in real life.
We saw some good usage of the
AWS Compute Optimizer tool
to right-size your
workloads in other ways.
You may be wondering how
you can start assessing
the savings that are
possible in your environment.
So as GP mentioned, we do
have these self-service tools
in the AWS Console.
Compute Optimizer is
a great starting point
if you like to get in the
data and do it yourself.
But the OLA program is
here to support as well,
wherever that would be useful for you.
So Compute Optimizer does have
the resource utilization data.
You'll see your CPU memory
IOPS throughput usage there.
It doesn't quite yet since
this feature of Optimize CPU
for License Included
was just released have
the recommendations on
whether you should disable
hyper-threading, whether you
should just reduce the vCPUs
instead of changing the instance type.
So that's where OLA can
step in, in the interim,
while they're rolling out those features
to AWS Compute Optimizer.
For existing AWS workloads,
this program is programmatically available
for any customers that are
carrying AWS Enterprise Support.
This criteria is really
just tied to the fact
that when customers
have Enterprise Support,
we have permissions to the necessary data
to do the OLA savings analysis.
So this is actually a very
quick exercise for us.
For you who are already running in AWS
and carrying Enterprise Support,
we can turn around the OLA insights
in less than a week usually,
and it requires almost no lift from you.
The only thing that would require lift
is really you tagging your SQL,
Bring-Your-Own-License workloads
if you are using any of those.
So in order to launch this assessment,
most of our sellers will be
familiar with the OLA program.
AWS is a big company, so
your specific account manager
might not know about the program.
So ask your AWS account manager,
ask your services
partner, if you're working
through a partner about launching an OLA,
or you can use the QR code that is here.
This will just pop up an email
that asks some questions
about your environment
and sends those responses
directly to our team,
so we can get you started on your OLA
for your existing EC2 environment.
For your non-AWS workloads,
the program is also
available for all customers.
We do see, since these savings
that we've reviewed today
are so Microsoft focused, that
it makes the biggest impact
when you have around 100 Windows
Servers or 10 SQL Servers,
licensable SQL Servers
in your environment.
But we have the offering
for all customers.
Again, reach out to your
AWS account manager,
say you learned about OLA at re:Invent
and they should know how to launch one.
If not, you can contact us
through this direct QR code as well.
Awesome, all right.
So here we've talked a lot
about Optimize CPU for
License Included today.
The census feature was
so recently released.
We've just started to analyze
customer environments.
I have some savings from the
last month of assessments
that we've done that I'll show you.
But in the meantime, we
have these blog posts,
we have the user guide, we encourage you
to check out that documentation,
it's very thorough,
and there's a lot of self-service tools
that can help you get started immediately.
Give you a minute in case
anybody wants the QR code.
Awesome, all right.
So these are just a
handful of results, again,
these savings are pretty preliminary
since we just released the feature.
But I tried to provide a
range of customer sizes
and sample savings.
We have a customer with $2
million about EC2 spend.
They had projected savings
of 15% on their EC2 compute
just from the Optimize CPU
for License Included features.
So again, this is
incremental to right-sizing,
this is incremental to other
SQL reduction opportunities
we discussed like
non-prod, Dev downgrades.
So 15% of savings that
weren't achievable before
are now possible.
And even more impressive savings
for a medium-sized customer
that probably wasn't very
optimized, 30% savings for them,
10% savings for another customer,
24% savings for an extra large customer.
On average, what we're seeing right now
is around 20% savings.
Again, it's not a huge dataset,
but that's about where we
expect the savings to land
on average, 20% on your
overall EC2 compute
just from this one strategy.
All right, so we've talked
a lot about OLA today.
Today, OLA is a guided program.
We have self-service tools
like the one GP mentioned,
like AWS Compute Optimizer.
Today, the OLA program is guided.
So you engage AWS we...
I either work with you directly
or sometimes you'll work
with a certified OLA partner.
We'll help you run the data collection,
we'll do the analysis, we'll
read out the insights to you.
But in an ideal world,
this would all be automated
and that is what we're moving towards
with our tool called AWS Transform.
So this is available to
you in the AWS Console.
And over time, the OLA insights
that we've reviewed today
are gonna roll into AWS Transform.
It's not quite at parody yet,
but we encourage you
to be an early adopter.
Check out the tool, see
what types of migration,
recommendations, and licensing insights
you can already get from it today.
And provide us feedback, let
us know what you think about it
so we can continue enhancing it.
All right, today's session
was heavily focused
on Microsoft workloads.
That was on purpose, but
we do wanna do a quick plug
that for all major workload types,
we have an assessment offering
under the OLA program.
So we have modules for EUC for storage,
end user computing for storage,
for VMware, for Oracle.
So let us know what your
mix of workloads are,
or your account manager,
or your services partner,
and we'll make sure we
customize the assessment
to what you have.
And again, we just have the QR code
if you would like to reach
out directly to the OLA team.
All right, we are just
about ready to wrap up.
I have the various QR codes
on the next two slides
that we reviewed throughout the deck.
So our Optimize CPU for
License Included blog,
requesting an OLA, and learning more
about AWS Transform assessments.
Give you a minute for those.
On the next slide, we have a link
to our Skill Builder AWS platform.
And this is a training platform
with trainings on every AWS
topic that you could imagine.
There's over 1,000 deep dives.
So whatever topic you are interested in,
we encourage you to check out
our Skill Builder platform
to continue your Amazon
AWS learning journey.
So this will link you directly
to the Microsoft workload section
of that Skill Builder page,
but again, lots of trainings
available to you there.
Awesome, so I'll wrap us up
with a couple key takeaways.
We've talked about three main
things in this presentation.
First, Microsoft licensing is complex,
but we have the OLA
program available to you
to provide clarity on
the best way to migrate
your Microsoft workloads to the cloud.
Second, is that we have our
very new exciting Optimize CPU
for License Included features.
We're really excited to see
how this can make License
Included offerings
more cost advantageous for customers,
and really reduce that
license compliance management
that they have when they
contract directly with Microsoft.
And finally, AWS Transform is the future.
We wanna make this as accessible
as possible for our customers.
So we will continue to iterate
and bring these optimization
insights into AWS Transform,
and we encourage you to check that out.
Thank you very much for joining us,
for spending the whole hour with us.
We look forward to partnering with you
on your migration journey
or optimizing your
existing AWS environments.
We'll be around if you have any questions.
Thank you very much.
If you don't mind filling out
the survey in the mobile app,
we would really appreciate
it, enjoy re:Invent.